[Musica]
non sono la scienziata non sono nemmeno
medico
però cinque anni fa la mia vita ha preso
la svolta
che mi ha costretto di imparare tutto
sulle malattie genetiche aree
prima che vi racconto la mia storia
voglio presentarvi mia figlia mila
in questo video breve
[Musica]
nome di
salmoni sanza e amico
ma installare la nostra bimba si chiama
mila vergini e marco vezze renata del 5
novembre 2010
quando ripenso a mila appena nata era
tutta sorrisi ai salute
mezz'ora dalla nascita mila sagra po il
mio dito con una forza tale che avrebbe
tutto quasi sollevarla dalla culla
quando mila era piccola si arrampicava
camminava in montagna e correva
[Musica]
era molto attiva amava andare in bici
giocare nella neve andare in slitta
a un certo punto ci siamo accorte chi
mila si ripeteva diceva mamma ma ma devo
mamma devo in uno riusciva a continuare
poi verso i tre anni abbiamo notato che
aveva cominciato a camminare in modo
strano con i piedi leggermente i torti
e quattro anni ha cominciato a portarsi
i libri vicino agli occhi
[Musica]
poi a cinque anni i suoi piedi hanno
cominciato a muoversi velocemente
scalpitando e spesso cadeva all'indietro
e ogni volta che si rialzava cadeva e si
rialzava e cadeva di nuovo
l'abbiamo portata da molti specialisti
che però non sono mai riusciti a capire
cosa avesse
il tempo è passato e un solo mese è
cambiato tutto
ci siamo accorti che mila aveva perso
completamente la vista
[Musica]
quello che le dava tanta gioia era
giocare leggere e guardare la tv e
giocare con suo fratello
ma all'improvviso non riuscivo più a
fare in nessuna di queste cose è
devastante vedere una bimba così vivace
e socievole che non riesce più a giocare
con gli altri bambini nei con i
giocattoli perché non può più vedere
elmo in tv
[Musica]
milano è nata sana
era come tutti gli altri bambini in
colorado
camminava in montagne
sciava arrampicava
cantava
però verso quattro anni
iniziava avere i problemi
cadeva spesso
balbettava si metteva i libri e giochi
vicino avviso
l'ho portato giro a circa 100 visite ai
con medici con te le piste ma nessuno
riusciva a capire cos'è il problema
finalmente l'ho portato in ospedale a
sei anni la pronto soccorso perché non
sapeva più cosa fare
e lì e
hanno dato la diagnosi di pattern una
malattia genetica rara
ma era una malattia mortale
all'inizio devo ammettere che era
contenta perché finalmente abbiamo
trovato il problema
però contempo ho letto di batten e mi
sono resa conto
che va a tenere una delle malattie più
grave che esiste
nessun bambino ma è sopravvissuto 10 11
12 anni in quel momento mila aveva sei
anni
ho iniziato da geni tutto ho detto tutto
nei giornali di medicina di scienze e ho
iniziato a parlare con i ricercatori
come medici con chiunque
che lavoravano in questo mondo di
malattie genetiche
ho parlato con altri genitori che anche
loro compattavano per i loro figli
e mi sono resa conto se io non facevo
niente
nessuna speranza per villa
e quindi ho creato una fondazione
e ho iniziato a lavorare per una cura
ho raccolto
soldi
ma poi c'era un problema
perché la malattia di milan tipo di
malattia dove c'è una mutazione che
viene dalla mamma anche un altro del
papa nel caso di bilal hanno trovato
solo una e nessun laboratorio
riusciva a trovare l'altra mutazione e
quindi con social media
cercavo un laboratorio per aiutanti
trovare l'altra
per fortuna l'ho conosciuto un dottor
niù a boston c'è urgenza spero
che per fortuna mi ha offerto di aiutare
per settimane e lui tutti i suoi
colleghi ma non cercato questa mutazione
che mancava e finalmente l'hanno trovata
ma rosato per testare il mio figlio che
in quel tempo aveva solo due anni
per fortuna mio figlio non aveva date
però ha confermato che mila invece aveva
dato
e non c'era una cura non c'erano neanche
quasi scienziati che lavoravano su
questa malattia così rara
quando dottor view ha trovato la
mutazione
ha avuto un'idea una idea di una cura
e oggi non ho il tempo per raccontare la
storia di quello che è successo dopo
quell'anno ma in un anno solo dottori
che tutti i suoi colleghi hanno
sviluppato una medicina
protestato e dopo un anno ci siamo
trasferiti da colorado a boston e mila
iniziato una cura nuova che ha preso il
suo nome
milano prima che mila iniziato b la sen
aveva
le crisi epilettiche
da 20 a 30 al giorno
ha perso la vista completamente
quasi non riusciva più a camminare
molto poche ha iniziato mila sen
abbiamo visto che la medicina non solo
affermarsi fermata da malattia ma
c'erano i miglioramenti
mentre prima non mangiava più per boca
sia un amen tava per sondino
invece dopo trattamento iniziava a
mangiare di nuova per bocca
riusciva a fare i passi con il mio
system sostegno
non c'erano quasi più le crisi
epilettiche
e più di tutto iniziava a sorridere e
ridere di nuovo
questo è il primo anno come nel secondo
anno non era molto chiaro se la malattia
si fermavano
sembrava più o meno stabile
però nel terzo anno
la malattia di mila ha continuato a
progredire
quest'anno febbraio
lo spirito di milan ha lasciato il suo
corpo
è oggi
sto cercando di vivere
in un modo diverso
tutto quello che abbiamo fatto per mila
non era in tempo per lei
però la sua storia
ci ha fatto vedere quello che è
fattibile oggi cioè
sviluppare una medicina
personalizzata
ma solo una singola persona
tradizionalmente
le medicine vengono sviluppate
per il centinaio di migliaia di persone
ci vogliono dieci anni e circa 12
miliardi di dollari
però per le malattie rare
questo non è adatta perché ci sono
gruppi piccole e c'è un'urgenza
oggi
ci sono 300 milioni di persone nel mondo
con malattie rare
che per metà sono bambini
di queste metà ci sono circa 60 milioni
di bambini
con le malattie rare che sono mortali o
che sono gravemente
invalidante
60 milioni questo è la popolazione
dell'italia oggi
oggi ci sono
9.000
malattie rare diverse
e questi ci sono cure solamente per 5
cassetti
gli esperti pensano che ci saranno in
totale circa 15.000 perché vengono
scoperte in nuovi malattie più o meno
ogni giorno
questo ritmo ci vogliono due di leali
per curare tutte le malattie rare come
bud e
questo non è accettabile
il problema delle malattie genetiche
rare è gravissima
e grave come il cancro è grave come
aids è grave come kobe
è una situazione così grave
per tutte società
non solo per le famiglie come la mia ma
anche per l'economia
dove solo negli stati uniti è solamente
con circa 400 di questi malattie rare
costava mille miliardi di dollari
ieri non c'era niente da fare con le
malattie genetiche rare
non c'erano cure non c'erano terapie
però oggi abbiamo la capacità di
diagnosticare i bambini alla nascita
e di sviluppare le medicine
per queste malattie
prima che iniziano i sintomi
col milan noi abbiamo dovuto scalare il
monte di everest senza le mappe senza le
corde senza l'ossigeno
ci saranno anche altri che riescono a
scalare questa montagna però quanti
e la responsabilità di tutti noi di
rivoluzionare il modo di sviluppare le
medicine per le malattie genetiche rare
milan ci ha fatto vedere la strada ci fa
ci ha fatto vedere quello che è
fattibile il rendere possibile
inaccessibile
una medicina per una singola persona una
medicina personalizzata
però ora dobbiamo scalare questo
processo
per rendere accessibili queste medicine
a chiunque ne possa beneficiare
ci saranno rischi
ormai questo fa parte della medicina
però dobbiamo
pesarle con il rischio di in azione
senza la salute non c'è una vita è ormai
solo di milano nell unica
ci sono 60 milioni di bambini ognuno con
una famiglia che soffrono quello super
2000 ci ha regalato
una strada nuova
ora tocca a noi di cambiare e
rivoluzionare il modo di pensare
alle medicine e le cure per le malattie
genetiche rare